Oh
bea, let's
talk about when I was still a kid The
era was a
battle between people, McKee Konoha was in an unprecedented shortage of strength due to the long-running war involving various countries And
that's what
happened at the bar
I'm always here  It was my first mission when I became
Kakashi Gaiden Next time Kakashi Gaiden Senjou no
Boys' Life It's
all about me, the
inside of my soul's body is in the world of RPGs
Why is it okay to be a white blood cell and a king
?
So buy the human body is a microcosm
eh ah ah
ah
424 is z here too point boo it's pointless
just 0 point is 10 Chobimonokai
j
Now if you're betting your life on the game
show the strength of your vitality  Look, search,
ana
n ame
nan,
then sing What time is the new 3 hours?  Let's
go